hi everyone welcome to led live are you
unknowingly practicing idolatry find out
on this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness hello everyone
welcome back again
today we will be talking about something
that is
really popular right now it's kpop
do you guys know k-pop do you have any
idea what k-pop is
i have little to no knowledge on k-pop
other than it is from korea
and it's very famous people that i can't
tell if it's a boy or it's a girl
a lot of people ask us to cover it so
i'm glad you're covering it
and when i was years ago when i worked
at hot topic it was j-rock that was big
japanese rocks right yeah really
interesting so k-pop korean pop music
yeah yeah so i was always confused as to
why people who didn't understand korean
were into it but maybe that's just my
ignorance do they
sing in english sometimes sometimes yeah
okay
but mostly in korea yeah i don't really
understand korea
i mean i don't understand but it's just
the beat
people like what is this so what was
that what was the korean guy that sang
that one song and he got really famous
about that one song
open gangnam style
so is that considered k-pop as well i
think
i mean don't have old school k-pop right
he just got
older he was kind of older but i think
k-pop i think
like american boy band yeah yeah like
or backstreet boys you know who that is
yes yeah okay except there's
girls that are considered k-pop too like
girl bands so like spice girls something
like that
yeah like a girl usually yeah usually
there's so many people cringing right
now i'm so sorry
we want to thank our patreon
you really helped us to make all this
show possible
and put this show up for free on youtube
so
if you want to support us you can click
the link below and you can also get some
extra content such as behind the scene
and some
exclusive videos that is not here on our
channel we also got t-shirts if you guys
like some of the shirts you see out here
we come up with new ones we try to do it
every week but that really helps us out
and you also get a chance to wear your
witness so it's something that you can
get and you can wear and it also helps
us little light studios actually
produces dvds i know many of you younger
generation probably
barely know what that is but we have
discs
available with various different topics
you can find those on
dot tv or you can digitally rent them on
vimeo other ways you can support us are
amazon
smile they actually give us a half
percent
of your shopping experience which
doesn't sound a lot
a lot but every little bit helps also
another platform that we're on as a
giving assistant
and you can choose how much you want to
give with that one
so checking both out i think there are
browsers extensions for each one so when
you're shopping you get a reminder
hey you can donate to this cause and for
those
of you that have been watching our
channel from time to time and you guys
are subscribed thank you so much
but i want to make an appeal right now
we're so close to a hundred thousand
subscribers
if you have not subscribed to our
channel please consider doing so
we want to just see that i don't know a
hundred thousand just sounds like a good
number right
here we actually have a lot of big plans
yes we are actually doing a giveaway for
the lots of giveaways so
you know definitely hit that subscribe
button and uh we would love to
give you guys something i know what i
was going to talk about um
we actually started we have our own
bible school
so if you want to study the bible more
you want to get deeper into the bible
you can learn just go to lls.tv
towards slash bible school we'll put
that link in the description below
but check that out you get access to all
kinds of different bible studies
and you just go at your own pace and you
can study the word of god on your own
scotty cool bottle thank you i i had it
all
colorfully stickered up right we have
stickers and we've like been really
expanding our stock here michelle
awesome job um but yeah we have
t-shirts that match with stickers that
you can put and we have a bumper sticker
as well
for your car if you're interested go to
little studios dot tv slash
shop these are some examples of kpop
these are the popular ones the biggest
one right now is um bts
right i've heard of that yeah any of
those groups i think in
this one the one in gray background
that's
bts yeah so here's my guess is like
there's going to be the bad boy
the sweet cute guy the like you know
mean
whatever the one with blue eyes yeah the
guy with silly hair
is it common in k-pop k-pop let me make
sure that i say that right
um is it mostly groups or is it singular
people as well
the one uh that i know or the popular
one right now are mostly
in groups okay but there there are some
of the
single one the one that used to be in
group but you know right now it's doing
so well
yeah okay so what is kpop
if you can see the picture that's one of
the first k-pop
pen okay if you can notice that that
looks totally different
from the k-pop yeah
okay what year was that it's around the
80s
okay oh wow yeah i think that's probably
just pushing close to the 90s
so yeah so k-pop is short for korean pop
so it's
it begins in it's actually in 90s
in april 11 1992 when this group called
seo taiji and boys performed their
single
non-arayo or i know on a talent show
so that was the first time when a pop
group performed actually
because through before
1987 the country radio broadcasting was
really restricted by the
government they're trying not to get a
lot of influence from outside of korea
so these these people that perform this
song called i know it's actually the
first time
song that represents modern american
culture mixed with
korean culture why was it american
culture because
after the 1980s they began to
more open up to accept you know those
radio station or tv station oh okay so
like our music slipping in over there
yeah and some influence it's not funny
it's like
you know we have this influence of
eastern philosophies and eastern things
coming in here and
over there they have western things
coming over to them i mean hollywood
really infiltrates the entire world i
mean really everyone in the world
watches
something that comes right out of
california right yeah so
and then after that between the 19
1995 to 1998 these people actually
created
uh music studios like in here
what kind of music like young money
something like that but
they have sm entertainment
and yg so those three are the big labels
the big labels there
if you want to become a a group that is
successful you have
to be signed by them under them
and what's interesting for me is they
call this group
of singer as an idol group
they call them idol group yeah isn't
that funny that even in our culture i
mean we have american idol we have
things that's like
they just don't even hide the fact that
they're like yeah these are
modern idols yeah all right they're
stars which we know
biblically are like you know angels or
whatever right
uh celebrities are to be celebrated and
they get their own star and
yeah interesting right and and listen to
this what is
the definition of idol based on this
article that i found
so an idol is meant to be admired if not
worshiped because it represents some
degree of perfection
perhaps that is why mainstream korean
celebrities are called idols
kpop idols must appear good mannered and
good looking at all
times to appease the somewhat
conservative by north american standard
sort south korean public so in short
there are these idols are groups of
artists singer rapper
or dancer that that are perfect and
meant to be idolized or worshiped
no that's pretty terrible but i have to
admit at least there's a standard
you know you have to be well-mannered
it's making me think of like the disney
you know all those mouse what are they
calling the musketeers
yeah mickey mouse club you know they
they start them out as all wholesome
stuff but then you look at like miley
cyrus and
justin timberlake and all that like yeah
you're creating something that
is safe for kids and parents think it's
okay and then
that kid continues to idolize them up
into adulthood
and now you're swinging from a wrecking
ball naked and stuff like that but
doesn't disney have that
um i would not i don't know the official
word but once you're
a part of disney like as a as a kid oh
yeah because you're inside
contracts like you are not allowed to um
hang out in certain circles and do
certain things and you can't have
certain relationships so that's what
they're trying to accomplish like a
certain image
so i guess once they break out of their
contract then they get their childhood
back
and they start so isn't it isn't that
interesting that you know the bible
cautions us obviously in the ten
commandments against idolatry right
right
and and what do you want to do what do
you want to be with your idol you want
to be
like your idol right and and look at how
god is like
no like i should be your god because you
should want to desire to be
holy like me and the devil's just taken
that and twisted and given us some
faltering yeah i i actually i don't know
i think somebody told me that it's
become popular right now
young girls want plastic surgery as
birthday present
because they see that all of this
singer looking so perfect please face
understander
when they go with a deep end like that
though it's it's kind of really a
testimony to
here you're putting out this perfect
image
but without the power of christ
behind it to transform it and so it just
makes sense that it would fall apart
because that can't last you're not gonna
appear you know to be a perfect
image without christ working and living
and transforming you it's just not
possible
because we're broken simple human beings
so it makes sense that they would just
go off the deep end because they're
trying to they're trying to achieve
something
without god yeah and it won't last right
but the media doesn't affect people just
makes them want to get plastic surgery
for the birthday
that's funny so what does it take
to be a this group idols thing
okay let's see if mikey qualifies okay
all right perfect
yeah they start their audition at
very young age like how young like some
websites say nine most websites say
10 to 13. that's what they started still
playing with legos you know
it's crazy the pressure that that would
be put on these people most often
probably from their parents you know
wanting them to be famous or successful
yeah and their parents looking at it
like yeah this kid makes it she take
care of us in her old age
right so starting audition at 10 to 13
and then after audition they don't go
straight to become
the celebrity and then they will go to
the special school after that audition
wow so they go on audition and then if
the if the
producer or whatever see that you have
potential okay
sign up do you want to sign a contract
and then you're gonna basically go to
this special
school kind of stay in a dorm kind of
thing
so you're talking about it it's it's
education it's not school to be an idol
right it's
no no it's the school to be in front of
idol but they also go to a regular
school
but yeah it's just like an extra school
thing you have no free time then they
have
classes on like you know how to sign
signatures you know how to sign your
name
yeah how to handle screaming girls as
they're running after you
so so in this school basically it's kind
of like a mold you know
they rehearse so late at night and early
in the mornings
uh some of the articles say
the earliest day starts like 5 a.m
before school starts then they go to
school at like eight and then
come back from school and then rehearse
until like 11.
now i have a theory anybody that's
made it super successful in life
generally doesn't come with minimal
effort right you know what i mean when
you really sit down and you understand
how much people have actually put into
whatever
there's a reason why they're good at it
they've
they've done this for eons since they
were five years old you know
tiger woods there's a reason why he was
that good at
starting he started at three four or
five or whatever and played for
hours and hours and hours out of the day
yeah so if you did that with anything in
life
you'd be pretty good at it that's that's
actually one of the premises i was
telling kindy about this book it's a
book called
outliers by malcolm gladwell and he
pretty much says it's it's like 10 000
hours
if you can put 10 000 hours into
something
you know you're going to be like that
that expert
it was reminding me i've seen this
documentary about these um
kids that play chess you know chess
prodigies and stuff
and what's fascinating is the amount of
pressure that goes into that i mean
these kids are like
they're brilliant when it comes to chess
i mean they're just like you can play
they memorize entire games
from all these masters and you know they
can just do all these moves and
calculate everything and see the whole
end of the game and you're talking
millions of
moves you know they can see all this but
a lot of them quit
because the pressure is so intense and
it's like they're so young it's just
like
it's not worth it like i don't want that
yeah and
and this is my one bone to pick with
video games and stuff right because
people put probably that many
hours of video just thinking about abel
showing us that yeah
you know what i mean like yeah working
on working on the show with
with uh with our anime doc with abel um
you know he told me how many hours he'd
spent he showed me on the computer how
many hours and he logged
his things and i was just like man you
could have like a
doctorate by now you know i mean
literally it was a lot of hours
so you know you got to think about your
life has only so many hours in the day
and you know you can be good at
something what if you put that into
preaching
what if you put that into reading
studying about studying the bible what
if you put it
into sharing the gospel you would you
would be an amazing evangelist
right i agree and then you know i admire
these people they take all of this
effort
and time and everything and
also during their time in this
studio in the school they control
everything like they
control their their social life they
take their phone
they they're controlling also their
weight their
physical diet probably their diet so i
need that exercise
yeah in there this one is crazy though
because
uh in some of the website it says that
their maximum weight is 47
kilogram it's less than 110.
for a male
but they don't care how tall are you
what so you just
have to be that weights and if you are
not if you are more than that they will
restrict your food
or sometimes even just let you just
drink water
right so it's basically like prison and
also it says that
this studio life is grueling to the
point that it can't easily cross over
abusive yeah for sure i mean the
discipline is great but
balance balance and everything i know
yeah and and you think of the business
that surrenders
centers around these people i mean these
these are these are products for people
to make money with
so you're gonna you're gonna train that
for lack of a better term
uh circus actor right you know what i
mean to do whatever you want them to do
it's like i remember watching this
documentary on the elephants and
circuses and how they used to
beat them into submission right and it
was like
this is probably what they're doing with
these people as well they're just
literally abusing them but they're
getting a performance out of them
restricting you thinking about all those
athletes too like professional athletes
people like michael phelps
you get out of that and it's like what
are you supposed to do with your life
you know and how do you relate to normal
people right
all right i don't know i actually found
these stories of a girl
so she's not korean i mean she's korean
but she is she was born in britain
england and then all her life she wants
to be a
k-pop star so when she was about 10
she went to korea to do some audition
and then she catch the eyes of those
producer and then
when they asked her if she wants to go
to the school
they asked her to sign a two years
contract because that was the shortest
contract
available two years and she had to live
in a dorm
if the parents want to visit her they
have to ask for permission
to visit her wow yeah like even her
family if you just show up there
you may not be able to see her without
permission
so just imagine your kids like prison
yeah and she said that
she has to uh
[Music]
she live in the building with the other
trainees and she only
can uh have her phone 15 minutes a day
at night only 15 minutes a day now
there's a testimony right there for
somebody good to go
to realize for you to be successful you
need to take this technology
away from that person what does that
tell you
right but she goes to school during the
day she goes to school to normal school
and everything
she started to train at 5 a.m finish at
and then even in that group of the
the girls in the building in the same
building they also
divided into two the group a and then
group b
so if you're in group a you are most
likely
to be a an idol if you're in the group b
you're still you're not sure if you're
gonna be an idol or not
okay majors and minor leagues here yeah
yeah something like that
and they she said in her article that
sometimes they also even announce your
way
to everybody if you are like overweight
or
oh you mean a healthy weight if you're
healthy should they
try to shame you oh you're only 110.
yeah that's seven pounds
yeah so it's really crazy the life in
there
she said that uh she doesn't have a real
friend in there because
everybody yeah competing against each
other
and she eventually quit after the two
years is like she can't do it anymore
but then i was curious why don't she
just quit in the beginning
so actually if you try to quit before
the contract and you have to pay
everything
oh wow yeah you think about it so she
entered at 10 2 years later you're 12.
yeah i mean it's a baby right you're
still and you don't live with your
parents that's so sad
but what parent would give their 10 year
old up to something like that is beyond
me
like we can't see you unless we schedule
right and just knowing how our world is
and all the abuse and stuff that goes on
which are no doubt is probably going on
behind the scenes here
anytime around performance and and
entertainment you've got
you know predators and all kinds of
things that could mess with these people
so basically after this contracting
after school
this contract when you actually become
an idol signed to a group you need to
sign
another contract and before when it
first
began most of the contract it's five to
ten years and they call this slave
contract
oh they actually call it that wow it's
really long
because it's you know five to ten years
and
eventually recently i don't know how
recent they reduced that to
maximum 10 years i mean 7 years
max wow but it's still a lot and imagine
if you are
uh doing this 10 years contract in all
this group and then when you're done
you don't know how to live a normal life
again
yeah because kirkman if i'm wrong here
like atlantic records in those places
it's more
like album or project based it's not
years yeah is that right yeah yeah it's
like a three record contract
yeah because they probably know how
americans are like oh oh yeah
i got 10 years okay well i'll make you
album my ninth year
so yeah they have this thing called
debut you know so when they
first perform it's they call their debut
and then they have what it's called come
back
if people actually like them they will
make more album
but if people don't like them they may
disband
so their whole career is almost like an
american idol or something
instead of just like oh i want to make
another album it's like
are you gonna make another album yeah
let's ask the people
can they measure another album so it's
not necessarily
niche groups it's like if the majority
of people don't like you that's it
that's
it wow and you could have been a top
pick imagine that pressure
yeah you get all the way up there and
then nobody wants to hear you beyond
that yeah
they're all committing suicide that's
what i see the difference i think
between the k-pop and the
artists here in the u.s what i see in
k-pop is like the
the company uh control
what they do what kind of album they
need to make
and oh talking about the roles in the
group right
so this girl that i was talking about
she was picked as the visual in the
group
because they thought she has a good
looks and everything but they told her
like this
if only you had smaller jaw and smaller
nose
you can look better it's so bad you know
i'll tell you when i first entered into
acting
um everybody starts out doing
commercials so
you you know you're going through and
all these different commercials for all
these different companies
and stuff like this and they'll start to
tell you that no you're
you're not good looking enough like you
shouldn't even notice what are the
people saying it like butt ugly people
right they're behind the camera that'll
tell you something but but they just
knock you knock you knock you and and
it's like
people i think in the entertainment
industry have such a low self-esteem by
the time they
get to this place that if and when they
do make it
they're going to do no no they're not
going to do or they'll do anything to
keep it you know what i mean
so anything that those people ask them
to do it's like they're so fearful of
not having it because they've worked
this far and they've come this long
and and you're you're well think about
that psychology
your um your value
is a number placed on your head like you
know you see oh wow that that actors
made 20 million dollars right that's
literally a price tag on their head
but you know god tells us that we are
infinitely valuable to him
like there is no price the fact the
price that was paid was that
was the son of the heaven yeah that the
son of god that literally came from
heaven to to
to die and give you an opportunity so we
are to die for
we are price less yet this world's
mode of operation is they put a stamp of
approval on your head
now what happens if you come out of this
with nobody liking you you're not worth
anything it's like
why continue forward you know yeah
they're making you work for that
whereas god has said no i'll give myself
for that free
yeah yeah it's so sad to see
like all these girls that wants to be
like this and try hard to be like these
people
and they don't really know how these
people actually
are because apparently this agency
wants them also to have certain
character this girl she was told that
okay you have to be visual and you have
to be this shy
uh cute girl even though she's actually
a more of a
extroverted outgoing
so yeah they tell you really what to do
yeah right
that's like trying to tell sanguin just
don't say anything
[Laughter]
yeah okay so let's talk about the
fans okay and you know all every
uh music industry or everything they
have fans
and they're usually different and kpop
fans are interesting because
first they have this thing called fan
chan
yeah they call it fan chan so they're so
they're idols they get
chanted at fan chan is
uh alternate uh intros to the song
so they say like one line of the song
and then the fans say something else
okay and they have this light
light stick also so they imagine this
light stick
and they they're waving it what even
they're one
okay okay it's like a responsive reading
right you know i was thinking the same
thing like in church you know
you used to be like a person and then
the audience would read a person yeah
so so let me show you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
i
[Applause]
[Music]
me
my
[Music]
[Applause]
okay guys so i don't know about you guys
but throughout that whole thing i'll
just like
how you know if they're under 100 pounds
they're with this grueling schedule how
are they moving like that and i keep
like a show is like 45 minutes to an
hour right right and
tours are like weeks at a time i've seen
many videos of them just dropping
we're talking in the middle of the yeah
yeah yeah
you know and it's like they just pass
out and on stage and then somebody comes
up
grabs that guy good thing there's seven
more yeah but i mean is because they're
wasted
or because they're drained they i don't
think that
at least yeah because you know a lot of
people get
their hands high yeah yeah so so i think
that they're not allowed to
kind of like party in that way so i
think this is pure
exhaustion
that they're like yeah it was totally
stoned
yeah but i'm we're talking about people
who live like prisoners like
yeah they're coming in like shutting the
lights off and
we'll wake you up at five in the morning
for your routine or whatever
you're not talking like rock band type
yeah
yeah they're just they're just like no
rules whatever
okay yeah okay so yeah these k-pop fans
they do fan chant
they have light stick along with doing
the chanting thing
but keith made an excellent point like i
wonder how long these chants
last because if i'm paying to see you
perform why am i
chanting at you you know what i mean
they usually scream the whole concert
yeah yeah so i think and correct me if
i'm wrong here i might say something
that's probably not good but uh
is the asian culture they really like
like uh karaoke right yeah
yeah like literally have you ever been
to an asian country
i mean it's hilarious there's a karaoke
bar on every corner and it's like some
guy in there just
like literally he's singing his heart
out there's two people in the audience
you know
so i think it's a cultural thing yeah
culturally i think that they just like
to sing so i i would imagine that's
why they probably can't take a bank yeah
right yeah
everybody thinks they're a singer i like
how to do a show up and stand on the
stage i know
you sing to me and i leave rich well
what they
say they're doing the fan chant thing is
to support them and to show
unity toward them because every every
group have different channels i mean you
can spin that all kinds of ways
okay okay so i i want to just point
something out that is an interesting
observation here's a group that has
rules
very strict rules abide by those rules
they have a community that they want to
see unity
in right and i mean think about that
this is like
and people get mad at are christianity
yeah about the rules
yeah why aren't you calling out k-pop
yeah
yeah let's talk about the rules here's a
whole industry that centers around if
you step
out of line you are literally
excommunicated kicked out of that thing
right
god isn't like that right
that's a good point actually and they
also
attend concert or watch them through
screen
i forgot to put the video here but i saw
this video of these two girls watching
uh the korean concert their event
and they were crying like crying
hysterically
isn't that weird oh wow yeah yeah that's
weird like they got so excited
it was weird when it's weird i think
somebody goes into a building and
somebody walks across the stage
a couple of yards away from it
like this reaction comes out of you like
what is that like
would they do that if jesus walked by or
right i feel like i feel like that's
probably the only person that
would make me effective like that but to
think a human being is walking across
the stage
and you are crying and about to pass out
so you've met famous people
where you were like star struck like no
no
yeah i mean there was people that like
oh wow i've seen this guy's
movies or videos or whatever you know
like yeah you feel like you recognize
them or you know something about them
but you really don't
but i have seen other people freak out
like that and it weirds me out
yes because it's just like these are
just humans like literally if you've
spent any time with them you'd realize
they
they they do the same things you do they
have the same struggles and problems you
all sit on the same throne
and it all stinks you know yours
that's really not as perfect as we
thought that's right
and also these people usually they are
they buy
merchandise a lot a lot of merchandise
of them and
they put it on their wall okay i'm still
tripping out over
the parallels here look at this i i
can't let this get an offering
i can't let this go so here's a system
of the world that is all about selling
merchandise
right and and they're all about rules
and perfection
and look at perfection and nobody is
calling out this thing called k-pop and
being like
you're just a perfectionist right what's
wrong with you you're just trying to
make money
you're just a yeah you turn around and
you say that to the christianity when
when they're literally like hey there is
this set of rules that we want to abide
by
because it's it betters our
relationships we don't lie to people
don't steal don't cheat don't
uh you know commit adultery covet any of
those things right those are those are
things to
better the relationships that we all
have and people want to fight against
that
yet here is a whole system of very
strict rules worse
and there's until you have to weigh 110
pounds
right you know what i mean it's it is
i'm sorry i'm tripping out on it yeah
and you can see here i have some
pictures of the merchandise that they
have they have all this album and they
put it all over their walls
like this looks like a worship shrine
just like that
they have a cutout of their idols like
the size it's kind of creepy
yeah but yeah this is what usually the
fans
have so when actually they buy their
album they have certain the special
edition with the
picture of each of the member and their
signature
and it sells for more of course oh yeah
yeah and some of them are limited
edition
kind of thing see this is like across
the board you know it's not just
koreans or people who like k-pop that
idolize
celebrities you know rock bands r b
singers
video games all this kind of stuff
superheroes plastered all over the place
i think what's pretty scary about this
particular scenario though is how young
they start
yeah and the system in which they're
engaged in
really scary right and sometimes they
even have
like a whole just like a whole thing
a face of their idol you know like water
bottle like a whole face
of their bias they call i saw more than
one
american girl move to korea just because
she was a k-pop fan
like that's a huge step you're welcome
you're leaving the country just because
you like k-pop
i think that's what i see different from
these k-pop fans they're
super dedicated to their idols like
once they like it they always support
them
however wow they can you know all of
this only works because of public
opinion
yeah really right by that if nobody
cared
oh okay if nobody cares this would not
be an industry
wow so they constantly have to check in
with the audience
on how are they responding how do they
like this how are they
they they coming for lack of a better
term they're building a congregation
yeah right without that there's no
that's true there's
no message oh keith hasn't been the
church in two weeks somebody needs to go
check on
the same type of deal like are you
tithing or are you buying
it's the same with like gold and
precious stones and all that they're
only valuable because people think
they're valuable
right right yeah otherwise yeah they
wouldn't be
yeah right and also interesting
that they have is they have their pet
names of their fans so different group
of their pet names like for example this
group called exo
they their fans club called xo
l l for love and vip
is the fan club of big bang
and bts fan club called army so bts army
oh i just got so like beyonce beehive
that kind of thing
yeah yeah like black pink blink
twice and they also have some unique
group name
like twice and their fans club called
once interesting
yeah because i mean if you can i think
what they say is that if you can love
them once you can love them twice
interesting and this famous one called
super junior i don't know have you guys
heard about super junior sounds
yeah it's like this i think like nine
boys or more in one group and there
it's like slipknot they're friends
called
elf everlasting friends
call me an elf man what
so and then the other thing that these
fans do they get
awkwardly excited when they see their
idols
and actually there is this group of
extreme fans it's called
sessing sassing fans
so weapons sassing fans
so there are fans that are that invade
the artist's private life they're crazy
like some of them actually install
camera in their hotel room
we call that stalkers yeah basically
stalker yeah they install cameras some
of them trying to kidnap
the artist what do you think you're
gonna do with that person when you have
your
idol imprisoned in your home and against
their will
i mean it would be like you know a deer
head on the wall you just you just yeah
because it's not like you're just
hanging out that person doesn't want to
be with you
they're going to feel very uncomfortable
right so this is a video of this bts
[Applause]
group
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's how it is i say
yeah that's fun for how long i mean
yeah okay so you were the guy that
probably didn't get a lot of
attention in high school or whatever and
now you got girls chasing you
like yeah yeah but then you can't even
go to the grocery store or do anything
you can't even have a normal life right
it was like you said
you're like they're recording him doing
nothing he's standing there imagine if
somebody
bust in here was like in your face
it would not bother me if i didn't have
to go to the grocery store like ever
again and somebody else did
shopping
but it's like if you never were able to
engage in the public what a sad
existence as well
i mean i enjoy sometimes random
conversations with random strangers
instead of them being like dude
[Laughter]
for me personally i don't want to be in
that kind of
position you know the one celebrity i
met james gandolfini
who's that from the sprint the sopranos
oh
okay yeah join the club mikey
he was in outside of san francisco we
were visiting some
relatives and uh he was in one of the
redwood parks
and um just north of san francisco you
know over the golden gate bridge
and um i spotted him i was like wow that
totally looks like james gandolfini i
thought it was maybe somebody else
and i went over and i started talking to
him you know i was like you has anybody
ever told you you look a lot like
the sopranos guy he's like there's a
reason for that
i was like and you sound like him too
he's like there's a reason for that
so i was like trying to get a picture
with him and he's like no i'm not here i
think he was with his agent with his kid
but it's like you know he just wanted to
have a normal experience
and that's probably why he was out in in
the woods
you know he just wanted to not be
bothered and so i could respect that i
was like okay
yeah there's an example okay yeah maybe
you don't want to go to the grocery
store but you might want to go out
to eat with your family or something
like george clooney he says you know
i'm taking a walk in central park in
like 10 15 years or whatever
i'd like to yeah man that's fat
but well i guess not with the
chronoviruses and this is the best time
to run a mask and go for what go for it
because nobody can
yeah nobody can identify you okay and
also other thing that is unique of the
k-pop fans is
they do the dance cover of this friends
group because
all this group they they all dancing
while they're singing
so that's what make them also unique you
know people cover songs like they sing
it yeah they're covering it
that's what i'm saying are they doing it
on tick tock or at the cost on youtube
okay okay so let's
compare this for what the bible say so
first let's go to exodus 20 verse 4 and
5.
this is part of the 10 commandments
pretty sure everyone knows what it is
thou shalt not make unto thee
any graven image or any likeness or
of anything that is in heaven above
or that is in the earth beneath or
that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor
serve them for i the lord like
thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
do you think the use of the word jealous
here
that god saying he's jealous is the same
that we interpret jealous today
i think it's different i don't know
that's a good question yeah
if you looked at the hebrew itself it
was the same word that
means basically um you know that that
you don't want that affection to go to
anyone else you know what i mean it's
like reserved for you kind of like a
husband wife i think it means the same
thing but he's
rightful and just and feeling that way
he's the creator nobody else deserves
worship the way he does he created you
so when that worship goes to somebody
else
he rightfully so can be jealous of that
that's
for him and would you want it any other
way i mean what if god was like i don't
care
yeah it's not like you have ego you can
have 500 million other gods it doesn't
matter as long as i'm the supreme god
can you imagine what you'd think of god
if that was the case
all right it will lost your respect and
actually in the new american standard
bible
translation it says you shall not make
yourself an idol
so it's pretty clear that we should not
make ourselves an idol
and when we look at the what the fans do
they
put the image of their idols on their
wall or
whatever surface they can and they sing
to them they chant to them
yeah imagine if you were like i don't
know how to explain it except an alien
from another
planet or maybe some third world country
or something
and they walked into a house of somebody
like this they would be like oh who's
your god or whatever
because that looks identical they see
like
the hindu prayer room with the poster of
the blue lady and
the little statue and the incense and
all that like
we we we try to make justify and say oh
this is different or whatever
but if you had no reference of culture
or whatever and you just walked up in
here
oh this is your god who's that or
whatever you know
it's identical that's interesting you
know beyonce just released uh black as
king the visual album
and a lot of people are slamming it for
um it's
content i'll just summarize it that way
um for different reasons
but i think above that especially for
christians i think the focus should be
more on people's idolization of her
and putting her on this type of pedestal
there's articles out there actually
calling her god a god
um and how she how much she's doing for
the culture and if you say anything bad
about her
get ready to be attacked and um you know
i
i'm seeing how these people who um you
know some fans who are literally giving
their life
for k-pop right giving their life for
people like beyonce
like that is just their their world they
can't see anything outside of that that
to me is a lot more scary than an artist
having subliminal messages and their
videos should be dealing with people and
and their hearts you know that at that
time you hear the sound of the horn
flute
heart liar and sultry in symphony with
all kinds of music you shall fall down
and worship the gold
image that king nebuchadnezzar has set
up psalm 99 verse 5
says exalt ye the lord our god and
worship at his footstool for he
is holy okay so from these two bible
verses the daniel
and psalm and daniel says that you know
when
the nebuchadnezzar make this tattoo when
you hear the sound of music
you have to worship them and you see all
these people
that when they see this their idols
performing on the stage they go
crazy and everything and some say that
only god we should worship and we should
excel the lord our god yeah music is
such an influence
yeah it's interesting because like those
people crowd around
for the concert and they're all just
whatever looking at their phone
and then all of a sudden
the sound of the music like they're
going about their day but then the music
comes oh
right if you could if there was such
thing as youtube back when
the old ancient days and stuff and you
know you could watch bail tube
i guarantee you you would see the
exact same thing going on in their
worship ceremonies i
i guarantee it looked just like ours
today you know there was these big shows
there was these stages there was people
performing
and then there was people like bowing
down screaming worshiping and
you know a bunch of sexual immorality so
this is no different than
baal worship it's just in a modern form
right
exactly and mikey can you read ezekiel
4-3
ezekiel 14 3 says son of man these men
have set up their idols
in their hearts and put the stumbling
block of their iniquity before their
face
should i be inquired of at all by them
so it says that they're
set up their idols in their heart right
so
the idol i think it's really applicable
to our modern world today
we don't have to necessarily make a high
statue of the idol but we can
idolize somebody in our heart and
that's that is a form of idolatry too
yeah a high statute figuratively
right within us within our heart i think
we can do that with preachers
yeah you know we can hold people to a
higher standard than
than where we should be and that's the
same plane
yeah and usually when in the in the
bible time
or in two days when we idolize something
we think that
that thing is higher than us or it's the
image of perfection yeah put it on a
pedestal
right okay so the next bible verse is
we're gonna have a lot of bible verse
here so the next one is
matthew 6 21
it says here for where your treasure is
there will your heart be also
so where is your treasure where is our
treasure
if we are you know buying all these
merchandise
or going to the concert we're putting
our
means our money we invest ourselves to
them
so where our heart will be our heart
will be on them
that's true but what if we invest our
time in like studying the bible
or doing some kind of charity work
supporting ministries
yeah i've heard that the word worship is
really made up of two words right
worth and ship and it's like we we don't
often think but
that the act of giving tithe to the
church is an act of worship
right so if that is a form of worship in
and of itself supporting and helping
you know that god's work go forward
can that not be the same for the false
you know way of buying their merchandise
and paying for
you know their albums and all those
things it's like we're helping support
their work going forward and i think
that's an act of worship in itself just
the money aspect
right you know i think that's the
biggest danger who you pay your
allegiance to
alters your lifestyle you know so if
your allegiance is with christ you're
going to do certain things paying your
tithe being respectful of people
following the 10 commandments
if your allegiance is to someone another
human being
who has wavering morals or whatever the
case or is asking you
to spend seventy dollars for a t-shirt
and you go ahead and do it like
i see where god is just trying to put a
safeguard of protection like
don't put you or don't put anything
fickle on your throne put me there
right yeah and keith can you read
ephesians 5
15 16 please see then that you walk
circumspectly
not his fools but his wise redeeming the
time because the days are evil
okay so the bible say also you have to
walk
uh like wisely i think some translations
say
wisely and redeeming the time because
the days are evil
and some translation also say that kind
of use your time wisely
you know because you can't regain back
your time
like you said in the beginning the
amount of time that these people invest
on this
imagine if you invested on bible study
or
doing something that actually can
improve your character improve your
morals
and look at what kind of dedication
these people have to their work
is this from the second they wake up to
the second we go down
can you imagine if we christians put
that same amount of energy into
you know spreading good news to the
world if we just treated this like a
military operation and it was like
non-stop i mean i don't know if that's
healthy but i'm just saying
i think you could make a lot of things
happen if you really put some energy
behind it
speaking of using your time wisely yes
you guys have to check out the uh led
that we did on using your time wisely
you might find that a blessing
um especially if you are subject to
getting your time robbed from you in all
sorts of areas that'll give you some
good
information it's about time so it's
about time to check that out
all right candy micah for all people
we'll walk
everyone in the name of his god and we
will walk in the name of the lord
our god forever and ever so who is our
god
in who's we will walk
you know in god the universe or
god designed us to worship like that's
instilled into all of us
um and i think that people that go like
well whatever i don't worship anything
that's that's that's part of our human
dna right
and you know even even people who are
like atheist and totally into evolution
right they're still worshiping
the ideas and the science and the
everything like this right they're
they're
they're very much so in that same kind
of ballpark
and so um yeah i think it boils down to
who are you worshiping
where are you spending your time where
are you spending your money where are
you spending your energy
right and this verse micah 4 verse 5 is
like implying the same thing that
happened
in one of the gospels where jesus was
giving a parable of the man with the
empty house
yeah your temple cannot stay empty it's
either
what some other god or the lord you're a
god yeah you can't stay
without one even joshua i think right
that choose you this day
and scotty please read acts 2 21 acts 2
21 says and it shall come to pass that
whosoever shall call in the name of the
lord
shall be saved amen what a beautiful
promise i know so this is kind of
related to that
the verse that candy say if we are
walking on the lord
we will be safe but if we are walking in
the name of other gods
who knows i think in the end everybody
gets what they want right
yeah that's true you know if if you just
reject god and you're like whatever i'm
my own god
he lets you have that in the very end
and
and so you know you got to think about
that that everything
you do it it really is god allowing you
to make that choice
right and mikey can you please read
my phrase revelation 22 4 says
and they shall see his face and his name
shall be in their foreheads
and also revelation 13 17 revelation 13
17 says and that no man might buy or
sell
save he that has the mark or name of the
beast or the number
of his name so this is interesting also
i want to relate this how these
k-pop idols they have name on each
of their fans and in revelation that you
just read
that you know the beast they have their
mark
or the name in their forehead but people
of god also have the name of god
so we we choose which name we want to
have
the name of the beast or the name of our
god do you think this has any connection
to this push in society today of no
labels
you know i don't want to label this
relationship i don't want to label my
sexuality i don't want to label my
gender or whatever the case
you know are they running away from
what's to come
where there are literally only two
labels are you for god or for the beast
yeah that's interesting okay i want to
share the last story here
the story of balaam and baylor i mean
we may have comment or people out there
to say well yeah i listen to k-pop
but i don't do this i don't do i don't
go to the concert
i don't buy their merchandise i don't do
this i don't do that but
this story of balaam and balak is really
interesting
because if you're familiar with this
story
balak uh tells balaam
to curse israel so balaam actually
consulted the lord first but the lord
say you know
at first the lord say no you should not
go
but balaam eventually went but with a
condition that he should only speak
but the lord told him to speak
so several times balak told balaam
please curse these people
these israelites but
balaam kept blessing them instead of
cursing them
so veyla got so frustrated it's like
okay you can
just go but
and then if you go to numbers 25
in the verse uh first
first verse it says that when
israel dwell in him the people
began to commit fornication with the
daughters of moab
but wait wait in the previous verses it
just says that
they were just being blessed what is
happening
right there there is nowhere it doesn't
say in the in the beginning
but if we actually go to numbers 31st
and 16
it says this behold this caused the
children of israel
through the council of balaam to commit
trespass against the lord
in the matter of peor and there was a
plague
among among the congregation of the lord
so it's interesting like
uh i mean we thought that balaam would
bless israel but here it says through
council of balaam
israel falls and if we actually
go jump to revelation 2 14 it says
but i have few things against thee
because thou has their
them that hold the doctrine of balaam
who taught
balak to cast a stumbling block before
the children of israel
to eat things sacrifice and sacrifice
unto idols and to commit fornication
oh wow so it's really interesting that
uh you know balaam couldn't curse
these israelites but he said
if we cannot make them fall why don't we
make them
join this they'll worship people
so he found a loophole yeah so balaam
has a stumbling block so
uh i think i forgot in which part of the
bible but i know there's a story i think
uh these people started to
invite it invite the israelites you know
to join them to eat with
them to worship to worship with them and
everything and they
eventually fall without balaam
curse them so you're making a parallel
for the end times
where there's going to be followers for
god who are like well i don't really
worship k-pop or whatever but it's just
that first little stumbling block you
know
well i bought the little wand i went to
the concert no big deal but it's just
small steps like that right yeah so
that's actually what i kind of
want to go with this it's that
maybe we don't go to the concert or we
don't buy the
music we don't have their poster but
okay i'm just gonna listen to them a
little bit
the next time okay maybe i'm just gonna
buy this little thing
i'm gonna do this kind of that and also
about
the time also like using the time wisely
or maybe i'm just gonna listen to one
song
and then do a song and then the whole
album and then
yeah it's like it's also the morality of
it all right understanding
what these people are going through and
why as you said before because of the
public that's why this thing is
continuing on
so yes of course with the draw you're
it's like you know being against the
point industry but going to the website
every once in a while it's like no
you're funding it so you should you
should stop so yeah
morality and spiritually and all that
everything yeah
and that that is an excellent point and
because
no one needed to curse them they cursed
themselves right
by their association isn't that wow
see that that's actually scary you know
i heard
someone say that he his boss told him he
said you know i've never fired anyone
he's like what he said they fire
themselves
he said the job has certain sets of
rules
and when you choose to go against those
you fired yourself
and that's really how god's government
is like he's not
the one punishing you he says i want to
give you eternal life
this is how to do it i'm giving you the
way it's free
and then we are choosing not to do it
that's right
right but what's awesome about god is
that
even though we choose not to obey it he
still
tried to call us to go back you know
that's true
all right any other thing
no i love how this was like a good study
yeah
well it's been great and if you have
any comment or if you're
really into kpop or you're struggling
with something just leave a comment
below or if there is any topic that you
want us to talk about leave a comment
below or
reach us on our social media on
instagram facebook
email or even tick tock we have tik tok
now
all right thank you and see you next
week
[Music]
you